what do you mean
i mean no internet please no we didn't
have cell phones we haven't heard no i
was in high school i'd be like yo meet
after school 4 p.m at macy's be there
for like i'll stay to 4 15 if you hit
traffic before okay if it was like 15 to
20 minutes
you were like [ __ ] that's insane like no
yo where you at i couldn't imagine that
what people don't understand is the
consumer blockchain is the biggest
technology platform that's come along
since the internet and like the internet
changed the world it's kind of actually
hard to really understand
for all of you young [ __ ] for sure
you don't even know
i i got to college before i saw the
internet i'm very empathetic to why you
guys can't even comprehend because you
take for granted what you have but
you'll see you've all lived long enough
without the consumer blockchain the
consumer blockchain is about to do its
thing over the next 15 years and you'll
be sitting in this chair talking to some
youngster being like no you understand
yeah i was 24 before like the blockchain
got going and then you're like what